[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Mike in
Dayton Ohio hey Mike how are
you good Dave and George um I'll get
right to my question I haven't heard
I've been following you for about six
months and we paid off all our credit
cards and now we're down to nothing but
our mortgage but I have two Parent Plus
loans for my daughters
and they want to do that pay for play
thing for or whatever that's called that
extends them out and I'm 59 and a um
almost 59 and a half and I have a half
of I have $500,000 in
401K between me and my
wife and I also started a new job about
five years ago and I was putting a lot
into that and I have about
125,000 in that and I was wondering if I
should when I get 59 in a half if I
should use that that
125 and pay off them two Parent Plus
Loans how much are they one's
415 and the other one is8
technically liable they are not I
understand that they said they would pay
them back but but then they said they
weren't well they're they're going to do
that extended thing well that means
they're never paid back you understand
that yes that's why I extended plan is
30 years of not even making the
principal payment exactly the interest
no interest is paid and they don't even
make a principal payment it goes
backwards for 30 years I know the
definition
yes stupid government program the DMV
visits finance
class I mean that's what this is right
oh God I mean thank you Joe Biden I mean
yes can't string a sentence together and
came up with this plan oh my God it's
horrible it's absolutely horrible no no
no no no no you're going to get stuck
with it dude that's what's going to
happen so we might as well own that now
and be done with it did you have
agreement with the girls before they
went to school that they were going to
pay these yes and they they they paid on
them but they're they're it's go they're
going nowhere the
41,000 was originally
39 and the 18 was originally
16 so they're going backwards on these
already from when they took out the
loans how long ago was that oh gez uh
one daughter is 30 she graduated at 24
and she's 31 okay so we're coming up on
a coming up on a decade and what we've
done has gone backwards so the way I
analyze this is that pattern is probably
going to go forward we just discussed
that so how does that work out for Mike
well that sucks is how that works out
for
Mike that's what that's what I was
wondering and but you always say never
take out your 401K but I thought this
might be a good time at I don't take I
don't take it out prior to retirement
after 59 and a half is what you're
talking about where there's no penalty
and you've got 500,000 or you got
625,000 we're going to pull 60 something
out plus some taxes to cover these right
well I have my Roth is I have them in a
I have most of it in a
Roth so my Roth would be taxfree I have
about
44,000 in Roth yeah and the 18 would be
I would have about 15 I'd have to take
out of a the standard 401 401 cuz yeah
yeah you know what
I'm do you sense the cleanliness in your
spirit of what I'm talking
about yes because I just I got my
thousand I paid off all my credit cards
which was
12,000 and now I'm stuck with this is
the only thing on my credit right now is
this and my mortgage yeah obviously I'm
not worried about your credit I'm
worried about Mike and Mike's daughters
are not paying this that's what they
announced we're going to not pay it
we're going to pay it while not paying
it that's that's what they announced
because they signed up for stupid
government crap so trusting a
17-year-old's good intentions to pay you
back isn't going to cut it and so when
parents sign on the dotted line for
these they don't understand what they're
doing they're potentially decapitating
their retirement when they sign up for
this and it's heartbreaking to hear and
but Mike this is a stupid tax that we
just got to pay as we enter our golden
years and they're starting to look a
little more silver a little more bronze
so what's the um stupid new one called
the save the save plan which is absolute
the opposite stretch it out yeah it's
like the stay in debt plan they call
they nicknamed it save stands for some
acronym
stupid stupid D can't say the second
yeah there we go stupid asinine yeah I'm
just I'm thinking oh God so I mean
seriously it's a 30-year plan and when
they give you the thing based on your
income it does not charge you any
penalty or interest beyond what you're
doing but it it but
accumulates principal because you're not
even covering the principal with the
payment and and you know so you have
have to have a dror Phil moment with
these stupid things and go how's that
working for you you know it's not you're
you know you've been you've been
screwing around with a government plan
since you got out of school you're 31
years old it's gone backward $3,000 and
you announce to your dad that the way
you're going to help him out and honor
your word to him is that you're going to
pay this is not pay it again and let it
go backwards some more and now sticking
with a higher balance than you started
with ex
exactly that's that's the net that's the
net of this now these girls didn't know
that they didn't think that through but
that's what happens was a man plan
believe in a stupid butt plan coming out
of Washington
DC God Almighty we heard story after
story so aggravating and the bar future
podcast and the documentary of all these
people who were like well the
government's giving me such a gift to
lower my payment based on my income then
they wake up 10 20 years later and their
principal has doubled and now they're
really underwater and they're really
screwed the the guy in the other hour he
started with 100 and something thousand
200 something thousand now it just
balloons counting on the private or the
the public student loan forgiveness the
PS uh which is
not oh it's just you're going to give
dve aneurism America exhausting well I
just hate it for you guys because you're
getting screwed by your own government
the first way they screwed you was they
have to put a student loan program in
place for you to get $150,000 in debt to
get a degree in left-handed puppetry and
told you that was the way to success and
now you're a barista
and you're screwed and it's just awful
it's just awful and then they come out
and go we're going to forgive it oh no
we're not yes we are no we're not no
we're yes we are and really they don't
intend to forgive it it's they want to
keep you it's the biggest scam
perpetrated on the American public by
our government mathematically in history
the second largest scam was the genius
that invented the idea that we take your
taxes out of your check before you see
your check
if they posted a tax guy inside your
building and you had to walk out and
hand him cash out of every check there
would be a revolution in America
pitchforks torches because you people
would see how much of the money you earn
you're giving to this government to
misbehave you would see that but no it's
just kind of came out of my check I
didn't notice it yeah but it Tax
Collectors would as reviled as they were
we would name the guy Matthew after the
bibl be as reviled as they were in the
Bible post him inside your building
little Matthews and they're collecting
the check him and zakus they're in there
collecting your
check